something quite nice and you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
a muffin being baits the flour and the
baking powder in a nice touch of
cinnamon cinnamon muffins those
brilliant
pinch of salt that's really important
for the sort of overall flavor you don't
want the muffin to be too sweet
Muscovado sugar that's the refined brown
sugar really rich and somewhat spicy and
goes brilliantly inside the muffin and
then my crispy granola now we're gonna
put half of this in now and say the
other half just sprinkle on top of the
muffin give that a really good mix in
the center I'll have some fresh pear top
and tell the pears really important to
peel nothing worse when you're trying to
enjoy that muffin and you're negotiating
with a big sliver skin of pear slice
them round the core four sides it's nice
and nice and thinly generally muffins
contain around half of fat and sugar of
cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet two whole
eggs
this Milken followed by gently melted
butter
give that a good mix add that to your
mixture just start folding always do it
by hand
muffins are delicate dainty little
beasts don't overwork your muffin
mixture you want that mixture to become
nice and relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy your
tray and your little cups and spoon in
that mixture two-thirds full one nice
generous spoon you can tell the mix is
right because you've got our even
distribution of the pair running from
the top to the bottom just gently tap
your tray both ends that gets the mix
all the way down so they cook nice and
evenly take your granola now sprinkle
that on top so you have a stool texture
spicy pair and it's nice crunchy topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more luxurious now into the oven at
180 for 25 minutes users
[Music]
I smell delicious got a nice crispy top
just get them out and let me cool down
and I don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week when I'm
having muffins like that nice smell
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pan and crunchy granola
muffins
[Music]
that the vegetarian's delight useful